this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armories museum in the uk which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and on
today's episode jonathan's taking a look
at more of the iconic weapons from call
of duty modern warfare remastered wow
well quite a lot of collectors around
the world might quite like a 5.56
millimeter stone
but um but shiny brass nato cases coming
out of a second world war boutique
caliber rifle is a bit jarring make sure
to subscribe so you can check out all
the new videos including jonathan and if
there are any other games guns or
mechanics you guys want to see jonathan
down let us know in the comments section
below right let's take a look at some
more of the guns of call of duty 4
modern warfare
m60 not the m60 e4 which is what um i
think cod always called it the e4 is
actually very similar but um what's
modeled in the game is an e3 by default
it doesn't have the
four grip hence this one's called the
m60 e4
e3 but uh by default it absolutely did
have this
forward pistol grip which is somewhat
unusual certainly for the the 1985 6
when this revised form of n60 machine
gun came in because it's sort of well
it's only really useful for assaulting
um clearing houses cqb that kind of
thing it's not the not the traditional
purpose of a machine gun of course
that is facilitated by the bipod which
is different on the e3 as well as a
different gas system
slightly different gas system anyway
different furniture so a different
pattern of butt stock but it's still
reminiscent of the original vietnam era
m60
and this i don't know it's actually
quite robust but it has it has a look
and feel of being a bit cheap and
plasticky no offense to seiko defense
who uh redesigned the m62 i believe to
try to improve reliability because
certainly by then the m60 was was
becoming a bit unreliable and also to
make it more user-friendly they managed
to shave a fair bit of weight off this
thing it's still still hefty um but it's
lighter than the original m60 so i can't
remember how good it was in the original
game but they've done a good job of
modeling the e3 slashing for
we've got uh belt belts well just about
see the belt moving we've got links
flying out the side we've got the little
the carrying handle flapping away there
now in reality that does actually flap
about a fair bit so that's probably
reasonable yeah what can i say it's it's
the iconic m60 but it's not the iconic
variant it's safe to say that would be
the classic vietnam version with the big
grouped full grip now i can't recall how
how it is that we're coming across the
m60 in the campaign given the time frame
of the game it shouldn't be
it's not standard us military issue
certainly but it is the more mod it was
the last general service variant of the
m60 that for infantry m60s are still
around on vehicle mounts but um by this
point the replacement for this was the
what we call the gpmg
the m240
onto the g3 uh now the one i happen to
have to pull off the wall here to very
nicely section armor a sectioned example
just about seeing there the the infamous
rollers
that delay the opening of the bolt
on firing now uh i haven't just grabbed
this to randomly show you a g3 in the
game cocking handle sticks out at about
that angle and stays there in reality
it always
stays closed nicely out of the way much
harder to snag on something and cause a
problem just to prove me wrong it has
stuck open there but if you fire it it
would flick shut again quite a strong
spring in there as well so hey maybe
this one has a broken spring but then if
it did this would be flapping around
like a mad thing and it doesn't so
that's a minor mistake i think in terms
of sort of feel the g3 is still
semi-auto only clearly in a game where
you cannot change your rate of fire
especially that's the right choice i
think although it could have been an
interesting challenge to make people
trigger control it into either single
shots or short bursts because it would
be uncontrollable aiming at the sky
after a burst of fire both in real life
and the way it's modeled here cause
we've got a decent amount of recoil
quite a punchy sound it feels like a and
i don't like this term but battle rifle
[Applause]
we've got another instance of not quite
right iron sights which is probably a
deliberate decision to give you a clear
field of view that distance but um that
deep notch at the base of that 100 meter
setting on this drum that's where you
ought to be aiming you're supposed to
bring the front sight right down into
that little v there um here we're
floating level
with that yeah you could use it that way
i just don't know why you would because
you're losing the precision of using the
sights
the usp i happen to have grabbed the
only usb 45 that we have which is a
compact version this is the version of
the game is the full size and we do not
have a suppressed version it's one of a
range of models a family of weapons if
you will in the hk range the 45 being a
little bit chunkier than this nine
millimeter stable mates i do think and
the only thing that really sticks out
for me with this is how very quiet it is
um i think if anything they could have
made the mp5sd
a bit quieter because in real life
that's quieter than any suppressed
pistol i think well almost any surprise
pistol fair to say quieter than this one
due to the sheer volume
of the suppressor it's uh the holes in
the in the barrel that are drilled on
the mp5 to better expand and cool the
gases and reduce the pressure
differential all of that check out our
loadout episode on suppressors for a
refresher on that point is this one has
is your classic action movie slash call
of duty game
very very quiet suppressed pistol too
quiet but hey it does fit the feel of
skulking around with something that can
very silently kill
the only other thing i'd say about this
is it it does have that visible slide
issue that i've commented on before
where you might see a slide moving in
youtube videos that's that's a frame
rate thing um if you see a pistol fired
you cannot really
and certainly not if you're not looking
for it see the slide moving through
space it'll you'll see a blur you'll see
that it's moving but you won't see it
it's moving too slowly essentially but
this is a very common issue and i think
it's partly down to oversight in
modelling guns but also people expect to
be able to see parts moving on guns so
we might be stuck with it but a lot of
the um more recent games including the
more recent cod games actually do get
that right
okay i have freeze framed here and some
really nice attention to detail on the
ejected cases on this this ak they are
well first of all we've got the primers
dented which
as we know we like on this series well
modeled they're not they're not cutting
any corners there maybe not super high
poly like a like a truly modern game
would do but what i'm impressed by is
coloration so that that grayish color
depending on the lighting looks about
right for one of the various steel cased
types of ammunition that aks commonly
are used with so that would be a steel
case rather than brass and then
lacquered with a it's usually a dark
gray but this this looks like what you'd
expect to see
this fairly standard soviet surplus
ammunition and the gun itself is looking
good would expect cod to get aks right
by this point um what they technically
haven't got right is the name but that
depends on the level of detail that
you're operating ak-47 is the world over
what
any cholesterol rifle is called this is
an akm however and if you want to get
uber technical i think we've said this
before but ak-47 is the designation for
one of the prototypes of the ak there is
limited documentation that introduced uh
was introduced with the ak when it was
first launched into service that does
say ak-47 but it was never its official
in-service name the best kind of correct
as we know technically correct
ak-47 is not right but everyone calls it
that
[Applause]
something i noticed there that's a bit
curious and i can't recall if this was
the case in the original version of the
game or not but um just a random ak that
i've just grabbed this one happens to be
section which is quite cool it is an akm
pattern receiver not the same model of
gun as the game but reason for showing
you that rear sight notch
is very small
small notches or apertures are how you
have any level of accuracy with iron
sights basically with the exception of
large around apertures where your eye
naturally will center the front side in
it those can be effective out to quite
some distance but for
for a notch let's let's say that at
least it does have to be either a deep v
so that you can use the bottom of the v
for a bit of precision aiming or as on
the real akm a very narrow little notch
there not a great big open channel like
it is on this rear sight i don't know
why it looks like that
maybe they found the side picture a bit
too claustrophobic to use effectively in
the game maybe they just made a mistake
but otherwise the model looks pretty
good we've got a gp 25 as it says there
fitted uh grenade launcher that's the
standard or was the standard uh soviet
area era underbarrel grenade launcher
muzzle loaded so it's being loaded
correctly there and loosely that's how
it works in terms of its effect the
original modern warfare was one of the
first games to to vaguely correctly
depict grenades where the rifle grenades
or hand grenades they're not a hollywood
fireball they are a puff of smoke flying
shrapnel uh and a blast wave and largely
down to things like saving quiet ryan
especially blackhawk down which is
probably the
major influence on modern warfare the
original it feels more at least feels
like we're watching a war movie and not
something completely gamified so we
guess gamified gameplay but a sort of
very similar tude to use a highfalutin
word for something that feels real it's
not realistic but it feels real
our uavs online
well as an arachnologist who's a big
[ __ ] you into his job might say that's
a very nice looking scorpion sorry that
was appalling now the version i've i've
grabbed today uh is actually a
suppressed version i'm not sure that
that's possible to to use in this game
or not but i thought it was interesting
we've looked at scorpion before i don't
think we've looked at the suppressed
version otherwise though this is
identical to the one that's modeled in
the game and yeah they've done a great
job of updating the scorpion major
drawback of the suppressor if you can't
fold the star but we can see yeah
there's some minor minor differences in
how bits are shaped in detail on this
but
build standards changing over time it's
possible you could find a scorpion that
looks absolutely identical to that and
yet the receivers the grip they they
look to be well realized we get the
correct magazine body shape when the
magazine is pulled out of the gun but
what we're not seeing is the hold open
device activating device
here i didn't get a good sense of the
lug on the back either it looked a bit
like there was a bit missing from the
mag so i think that might be a little
under modeled if i'm being harsh rate of
fire seems a bit slow put a fair few
rounds through these um they're pretty
fast but i could be misremembering but i
think it is
i think the thing that comes across the
most is how controllable this thing is
if the ratify is wrong it's not that
wrong it's only it's only going to be a
slight um difference what's most
important is you've got relative
relatively low damage
relatively high rate of fire and very
very controllable even with that stock
folded the way the way the characters
gripping it like that it's slightly it's
like an awkward thing to hold there
isn't a
this at least has the has this
suppressor where this would get very hot
very quickly there isn't a natural place
to hold this you have to kind of try to
hold the
as much of the lower receiver as you can
and you inevitably end up interfering
with the magazine which isn't great we
don't like to do that that said the
magazine does lock in pretty well and it
doesn't seem to affect functioning so
what you need to avoid are these cocking
logs these sort of ears that come back
flying back and forth because if they
hit your thumb well firstly that could
hurt depending on where your thumb is
and secondly it's going to stop your gum
from working so you absolutely must keep
clear of that it almost feels like you
want to hold it one-handed and in fact
if you were going to do the hollywood
thing of firing an automatic weapon
one-handed this would be the thing to do
it with because it's relatively
controllable you'd still miss
wow well quite a lot of collectors
around the world might quite like a 5.56
millimeter stone
but um i'm being a little bit snide here
the eject ejected cases from this mp44
is what it's called i'm not i don't know
if the receiver is marked mp44 off
appear to be 5.56 millimeter brass cases
that's certainly not 7.92 by 33 which is
remarkably short even compared to the
762 by 39 it's all in the case length 33
millimeters 39 millimeters 45
millimeters which is what this appears
to be i don't know why they didn't just
use the 762 by 39 cases for the ak the
vast majority of 792 ammo
in existence has that a similar gray
finish to that ak ammo anyway so that
would have been a better fit i might not
even have noticed but shiny brass nato
cases coming out of a second world war
boutique caliber rifle is a bit jarring
which is a shame because otherwise i
have i do not have to reach for my
emotional support
because this is mercifully free in fact
for once this gun is more faithful to
history than the real one because with a
couple of exceptions from what i think
are probably troop trials this optical
site that's fitted to this example
was not actually
used on mass
but this is a a good rendition of the
scg or mp44 would it be in this
environment well some have shown up uh
notably in syria they did manage to make
their way to the middle east in
some
notable numbers a handful here and there
crate here and there the problem is the
ammunition the problem for the people
who want to use them now in the handful
of places where they've shown up is well
if you can get ammunition from
afghanistan or the tribal areas of
pakistan they actually make 7.92 by 33.
amazingly i think they call it 30 which
is weird but nonetheless that was a
standard caliber
up there so you can get the ammo
this is just as good in broad strokes as
an ak and hey the germans kind of did it
first uh we have the federal we have
other automatic rifles that you can
argue about the first assault rifle but
in terms of the concept and the doctrine
and the reduced power reduced case
length cartridge it was this puppy so
somehow its presence in a in call of
duty modern warfare as the first of
of its breed doesn't feel entirely
inappropriate and as noted they have
appeared in the middle east
now although the
very convoluted
stamped design of this gun is really
nicely represented here even the bolt
carrier group through the ejection port
is very really nicely modelled for
whatever reason they don't seem to have
put the marking in this case mp4s before
and in this case it should be unusual
before as well they don't seem to put
that stamped marking in there which is a
little curious the rear sight aperture
as with a lot of the other guns in this
game is a bit wacky it's far too wide it
seems to be designed to the width of the
or the apparent width to the shooter of
the front sight protector which is kind
of strange it's meant to be the width of
the front sight post
right so on further investigation we
have the
magazine that's a pretty really very
good
model of the bit of the magazine you
don't normally see i remember in early
shooters you'd take the mag off and it
would be basically just that in some
cases or at the very least there'd be no
feed lifts there'd be no visible rounds
uh this has visible rounds and sure
enough they do look like they do look
like five five six rounds but kind of
proportionately squished to fit the the
magazine but then when they eject they
certainly do look like full size five
five six there's probably perspective
going on here anyway the bullets on
there are really short and truncated
again to make that
fudged round fit the magazine this would
have been basically perfect if they
could have just got the rounds correct
we really appreciate you watching these
videos we are a museum so if you'd like
to support us there you can go to our
website and find out how to do that
whether that's visiting or dropping us a
bit of money we also have quite a few
social media outlets and we have our own
youtube channel fairly heavily featuring
me so if i haven't bought you to death
please do come and join us over there as
well either way we'll see you again next
time
[Music]
[Music]
you